a un lado arcos y flechas en el otro
equipamiento antidisturbios
como cada año los indígenas llegaron a
la capital de brasil para hacer oír sus
voces ante una nueva amenaza a sus
tierras
esta vez protestan contra una
legislación que reduce su protección
legal solo a las tierras en las que
vivían antes de la entrada en vigor de
la constitución en 1988 esta ley
limitaría sus derechos sobre territorios
ancestrales y abriría miles de hectáreas
a la explotación minera y ganadera
esta ley es dañina para las personas
indígenas para el medio ambiente y para
toda la humanidad no tenemos miedo ya
llevamos más de 500 años de lucha y
resistencia y seguiremos aquí hasta que
nos respeten
una nueva lucha en el contexto en que
las comunidades indígenas ya son
atacadas por mineros del oro que invaden
ilegalmente sus tierras
hasta el punto en que los líderes
indígenas tuvieron que viajar escoltados
por la policía hasta brasilia después de
que un grupo de mineros amenazaba con
incendiar su autobús en las últimas
semanas el presidente yair bolsonaro
visitó varias reservas indígenas del
amazonas y les garantizó la protección
de sus tierras por lo que muchos lo
acusan ahora de hipocresía el mandatario
ha apoyado muchos macro proyectos en el
amazonas' desde que llegó a la
presidencia en 2019 la deforestación de
brasil aumentó cerca del 50 por ciento
alcanzando un récord en los últimos 12
años